okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over the body system called the
endocrine system and in the picture here
is only here's three parts of the
endocrine system where there's more but
this is just kind of an introduction
slide here so let's go ahead and get
started we're gonna go over the
endocrine system and some of the major
parts to it alright so in this diagram
here here we have the eight major glands
if you're in my biology class that I
want you to know the the diagram shows
what are called glands of the endocrine
system and first of all glands are
simply organs but if you notice they're
all physically disconnected to one
another it's not like the digestive
system notice in this diagram the
digestive system all the organs are
connected to one another
the esophagus connected to the stomach
the stomach connected to the small
intestine small intestine connected to
the large intestine it's not like that
if we put back the diagram of the
endocrine system you can see that
they're all just kind of physically
disconnected and some of the jobs of the
endocrine system are listed here helps
control growth helps in our development
as we mature over the years and go
through the various stages of
development for instance adolescence and
puberty and into the our old age our old
age years and also the undercling system
also releases chemicals that help us
respond to our environment and so one
thing that all these glands have in
common and glands or simply organs and
that's what we call the organs of the
endocrine system so the thymus is a
gland the pancreas is a gland and one
thing they all have in common is all
glands make hormones and the hormones
are chemical signals that move through
blood so the thymus will release a
chemical signal called a hormone that
will move through blood and that hormone
will cause another part of the body to
respond in some way depending on what
the hormone is and so what hormones are
going to do in a moment we'll have a
nice little animation
this in a moment I'm going to show you
that hormones are released perhaps from
cell a they travel through the blood and
the hormone might actually attach to
cell B cell B would be what we call the
target cell
so hormones are released from one cell
and the hormones are received by another
cell we call that the target cell the
target cell is going to receive the
hormone and ultimately the target cell
is going to produce proteins so hormones
stimulate target cells to make proteins
and ultimately we're gonna go over in
just a moment two categories of hormones
so here we go here's category number one
of hormones let's go over that next so
the first kind of hormone I want to talk
are called I want to mention are called
steroid hormones steroid hormones have
recently got some bad reputation in the
world of athletics because there's some
cheater athletes that are trying to take
larger amounts of steroid hormones that
are produced by the body naturally so
one thing I want to stress steroid
hormones are naturally produced by the
body and in the animation we have a
sound in the middle releasing steroid
hormones into the blood so we have the
sound in the middle called the secreting
cell because it's releasing those black
dots that are symbolic of the steroid
hormones and so it's releasing the
hormones into the blood well let's
follow those black dot steroid hormones
here when we follow when we follow those
black dot steroid hormones notice how
the in the animation the the steroid
hormone is bouncing off of that v-shaped
receptor it's because it doesn't fit so
there are what we call target cells and
there are what we call non target cells
in this case the steroid hormone doesn't
fit that particular receptor on the
outside of that non target cell look to
the right there's a receptor inside of
that non target cell notice it also has
a v-shape
so the round steroid hormone just won't
match that v-shaped receptor so steroid
hormones have to be shaped properly in
order to match
the receptor of the target cell
sometimes the receptors on the outside
of the cell
sometimes the receptors on the inside so
what happens is in this case steroid
hormones are gonna attach to receptors
that are located inside of the target
cell in our animation a black dot
representing the steroid hormone just
attached to this receptor what happens
next the receptor and the hormone the
receptor and the steroid hormone go into
the nucleus and the hormone will attach
to a gene a DNA gene as member a gene is
simply a segment of DNA and a gene helps
to code for the creation of a protein so
the steroid hormone goes into the
nucleus attaches to a gene and it
activates that gene so it will produce
proteins that's the advantage that Titor
athletes are looking to obtain they're
taking extra amounts of steroids than
normal so they can produce extra amounts
of protein than normal proteins help
build muscle protein help helps to
recover from injury and that's the
advantage that they're the Titor
athletes are trying to obtain but one
thing to stress is that hormones are
naturally produced by the body so what
about the other kind of hormone let's do
that neck second category of hormones
well if the first category is called
steroid hormones the second category has
the very original original name of non
steroid hormones and like steroid
hormones non steroid hormones are
naturally produced by the body and in
the animation again we have in the
middle of secreting cell releasing a
bunch of these black circles
representing the non steroid hormone and
notice how they're going into the blood
and the blood stream is just carrying
them away well let's follow them
we follow here we have a receptor
located on the outside of the cell so
notice one of the differences some cells
have receptors on the outside some cells
have receptors on the inside a non
steroid hormone well attached to a
receptor on the outside notice how the
shape of the non steroid hormone and the
receptor match well in this case in this
case what happens next is that this is
gonna start a series of chemical
reactions the non steroid hormone
actually never enters the target cell
the non steroid hormone watched this non
steroid hormone is going to start a
chemical reaction a series of chemical
reactions where chemical reaction a
leads to chemical reaction B leads to
chemical reaction C and the products the
products of chemical reaction C for
instance will go into the nucleus and
will like the last time stimulate the
production of proteins so the target
cell the end result is kind of the same
thing and in that the end result is the
production of proteins it's just a
little different pathway that is
chemically taking taken a little
different pathway that has chemically
taken to achieve that goal of creating a
protein okay so here's our diagram
showing basically above the shoulders
three major glands the first one i want
to mention is called the hypothalamus
and like all glands the hypothalamus
releases hormones and so you can see
from from the notes right now the
hypothalamus releases hormones and what
it might do is the hormones of the
hypest hypothalamus might stimulate the
gland just below it called the pituitary
gland and when the pituitary gland
receives hormones from the hypothalamus
the pituitary gland might respond by
releasing growth hormones so one thing i
want you to see is that hormones
communicate I should say excuse me one
thing I want you to see is that the
lands communicate with other glands the
hypothalamus communicates with the
pituitary gland in this case
here's another list of things that that
the hypothalamus helps to control
hormones of the help the hypothalamus
help to control growth reproduction and
body temperature in the picture a
thermostat that goes on your wall of
your house just appeared while our
body's thermostat is set at about ninety
eight point six degrees Fahrenheit it
just so happens the hypothalamus is that
thermostat if our body temperature gets
too hot the hypothalamus will release
enzymes to cool us off if our body gets
too cold the hypothalamus will release
hormones that cause us to warm up we'll
have a little more on that a little bit
later moving on to the next gland okay
so the next gland I want to mention is
just underneath the hypothalamus it's
called the pituitary gland and one
important important duty of the
pituitary gland it'll release hormones
that help to control the water level
that's in our blood you know if we're
really dehydrated our blood might become
too thick and it's really hard for our
heart to pump and so the pituitary gland
will start the releasing of hormones
which actually will draw some water out
of our bladder where we're storing urine
and that helps to add more water back
into our blood another here's a one of
the more important jobs here of the
pituitary gland I just mentioned this a
moment ago is the hypothalamus might
release hormones to the pituitary gland
the pituitary gland receives the
hormones of the hypothalamus and will
respond by releasing growth hormones
growth hormones are sent around the body
and it stimulates cell division
stimulates growth and mitosis and so
this is a really important step as we go
and as we enter our puberty years and we
grow and we go through adolescence and
into puberty and then eventually into
old age moving on down to the to the
thyroid gland next moving on the next
gland I want to mention is in the
picture at the bottom it's kind of in
your throat area called the thyroid
gland so the thyroid gland releases
hormones just like all the other glands
and the hormones of the thyroid gland
how
to regulate metabolism growth and
development
they also helps to increase rate of
digestion of our foods when we eat food
the thyroid gland will send out hormones
that helps improve the rate of digestion
another thing that I know it's not
mentioned in the video but another thing
that the thyroid gland also does is when
it releases certain hormones will help
to remove calcium that's in our blood
and the calcium that's in our blood will
actually go towards helping form bones
so all the glands that you've seen so
far the hypothalamus pituitary and the
thyroid they actually all have more than
one job to perform there are the
hormones of the thigh of the thyroid
hormones of pituitary hormones of the
hypothalamus often have more than one
purpose they help control a variety of
bodily functions moving on down towards
down to lower parts of the body all
right so now that we've moved on down a
bit we come to the purple one label the
thymus and hormones released by the
thymus cause WBC's to mature so they're
able to fight infection WBC's stands for
white blood cells so when the thymus
releases hormones those hormones will
help white blood cells mature and white
blood cells are an integral part of our
immune system they help to fight off
bacteria and viruses and other pathogens
that might get us sick so that's one of
the really important factors or jobs of
the thymus is to help help a strengthen
basically our immune system moving on
down next to the pancreas okay so the
next gland i want to mention is called
the pancreas and i'm i'm hoping you're
familiar with in general that what the
pancreas does it helps to control sugar
levels of glucose that are in the blood
and so if if the sugar levels are
dangerously high the pancreas will
release a hormone called insulin which
will bring the level back down to to a
safe level
and so after a meal we have a lot of we
have a lot of sugar in our blood the
pancreas releases insulin to lower the
sugar to a safe level well what about
the opposite if our sugar levels are
ever dangerously low the pancreas will
release a hormone called glucagon which
is going to increase the level of sugar
back to a normal safe level let's look
at both of these in a little more detail
so when glucose levels are high after
you've eaten the meal glucose levels are
high the G in the picture stands for
glucose so notice how there's a bunch of
G's in our blood well now what's
happening is a bunch of insulin
molecules released from the pancreas are
attaching themselves to little channels
that are located on our cells so when
glucose levels are high the pancreas
releases insulin that attaches to these
closed channels watch what happens next
when those channels receive insulin they
open and when the insulin channels are
open I hope you can see what's gonna
happen next the glucose is going to come
out of the blood and into the cells and
so now that the glucose is diffusing
into the cells the one's high level of
glucose in the blood has been lowered to
a normal safe level so anytime we have a
meal after a few hours our food our meal
is digested glucose enters our blood and
sets off this reaction this is again
started by our pancreas well we just saw
what happens when glucose levels are too
high what about when the glucose levels
are too low
well here's a picture of our liver our
liver is gonna receive the hormone
called glucagon glucagon is another
hormone and it comes from the pancreas
let's zoom in to the liver here when we
do we see five liver cells and they all
just receive the hormone called glucagon
that came from the pancreas the liver
cells are gonna respond when they
receive glucagon they're gonna respond
by releasing
stored amount of glucose into the blood
so if the blood sugar levels if the
glucose levels are too low the level of
glucose will be increased back to a
normal safe level because the liver
releases stored glucose okay so the next
gland I want to go over is called the
adrenal glands and there's actually two
of them they sit on top of your kidneys
the kidneys are those brown those two
brown shaped objects in the picture and
the adrenal glands release release
hormones that helps to control our
fight-or-flight response I'll give you
more on that in just a moment so here we
have a heart beating normally well when
you're startled when you have a a threat
your adrenal glands are gonna respond by
releasing a hormone by the name of
epinephrine you might have heard
epinephrine called adrenaline they're
the same thing and what happens in the
animation you can see our heart has
begun to beat faster because epinephrine
causes your heart rate to increase this
increases our breathing our alertness
our blood pressure and so this controls
what we call our fight-or-flight
response in times of stress or if our
body ever senses a threat for instance
you walk into a dark alley and there's a
suspicious character coming at you your
adrenal glands will release epinephrine
which causes your heart rate to increase
and this activates our fight-or-flight
response in times of stress and times of
a threat people will just run away from
that threat that's the flight response
we don't literally mean take to the air
and fly other times when you're faced
with a threat or faced with a stress
instead of flight and running away from
the stress you might choose to fight the
stress and to fight the threat but our
adrenal maguey our adrenal glands give
us a boost by releasing a hormone called
epinephrine
okay moving on down we come to what are
called the gonads and first of all
there's two gonads a man
female gonads and male gonads well let's
focus on the female gonads first the
gonads male or female influences sexual
development now the name of the female
gonads you can see in the picture are
called the ovaries now there's two of
them even though the line in the diagram
only shows one but there's two ovaries
and the hormones released by the ovaries
are called estrogen and progesterone and
these hormones are released in very
large amounts when a young lady enters
the puberty years of her life and so
these hormones estrogen and progesterone
kind of influence sexual development and
here's a list of some of the effects of
estrogen developed breast tissue helps
mature the ovaries starts the menstrual
cycle preserves bone density you know
one of the problems for women as they
age they produce less and less of less
amounts of these two hormones and so
they lose bone density as they age so if
it were ladies as you age one of the
recommendations is regular exercise
because exercise helps to keep that bone
density but the ovaries are the female
go ahead and like it says they influence
sexual development let's move on to the
male gonads next in men the gonad is
called the testes and just like in women
the testes help to influence sexual
development only in this case sexual
development in men and so the hormone
that we're all familiar with is the
hormone called testosterone so when when
if when a gentleman hits their puberty
years of life the testes will really
will release a surge of testosterone
this testosterone helps to build muscle
helps to develop sperm cells this
testosterone deepens the voice so it
changes the shape of the vocal chords in
our throat area and again here's a list
of some of the effects of testosterone
it increases the
sex drive it makes men more aggressive
stimulates the growth of facial hair and
so when you look at the gonads of the
male and gonads of the female we can see
some of the key key points I want you to
know is that the sexual development of
men and women is greatly controlled by
hormones of the gonads okay so the point
of this slide right here is to show you
that glands communicate with other
glands for example when our body shivers
in order to warm us up our hypothalamus
I mentioned earlier is kind of like the
thermostat it senses that you're cold
and it's gonna respond by sending a
hormone not a very far distance down to
the pituitary gland I don't really care
that you know the name of that hormone
I'm just gonna call it hormone a so the
hypothalamus sends hormone aid the
pituitary gland the pituitary gland
receives hormone a and it responds by
releasing hormone B hormone B travels
through the blood down to the thyroid
gland the thyroid gland will receive
hormone B and send out hormone C to the
body
watch what hormone C does hormone C
causes the body to shake and shiver this
shivering generates heat
all your muscles begin to shake
uncontrollably that heat generates
warmth which warms us up so this is a
great example of how glands communicate
with other glands so if you want pause
the Daiya pause the video and examine
the diagram here it's a real nice
picture showing the major glands
discussed actually I want to show you
something else I found that I thought
was kind of enjoyable next so strangely
I found these pictures when I was
searching for images online of the
endocrine system and these pictures
really have nothing to do with the
endocrine system I just thought it was a
really neat ad campaign from the early
1900s that kind of shows the pathway
that people can take as they develop
over their years so this this young lady
in the picture she has two paths in life
which paths will
this young lady take will the young lady
at age 13 take the bad path on the left
and read bad literature while the young
lady take the good path on the right and
will she study and be obedient as time
goes by at age 20 is the woman on the
bad path and is she flirtatious or on
the right is she on the good path is she
virtuous if she devoted to family if she
devoted to her religion and age 26 is
she on the wrong path the left side is
the wrong path she's you can see she's
partying it up living the fast life or
at age 26 is she on the right path is
she a loving mother and by age 40 if
she's on the wrong path she'll probably
be a social outcast but the path on the
right shows an honored grandmother again
these have nothing to do with the
endocrine system and I'm not even sure
why I found these pictures when i
google-searched the endocrine system but
I just thought it was kind of a silly
way to break up this video because again
the endocrine system helps to helps us
go through stages of development and
when I saw these I just thought the ad
come to ad campaign was to Nita I had to
throw it in here same for the guys if we
have a path of that leads to the good
for the girls in a path that leads to
bad for the boys what will become of
this boy right here he has two paths and
in this case the good path is on the
left and the bad path is on the right so
at age 15 are they clean and do they
study that's the good path on the left
or at age 15 are they self abusive and
smoking cigarettes that's the bad path
on the right and if this continued at
age 25 are they pure that's the good
path on the left or on the right that's
the bad path are they impure at age 25
and at age 36 the good path are they
honorable and successful or at age 36
are they a degenerate and kind of just
walk in the streets and by age 60 if
they're on the good path they've lived a
well rounded in there in in this case a
grandfather
or at age 48 on the right are they a
moral and a physical wreck can these
these pictures have nothing really to do
with the endocrine system but I just
thought they were really neat when I saw
this social ad campaign from the early
to 1900s and another reason why I wanted
to show those pictures I wanted to I
wanted to give you a distractor I wanted
to distract you for a minute or two and
now that I've distracted you I think for
a minute or two pause the video pause
the video and try to identify gland
abcdefgh
I'm gonna go the go over the answers but
pause it and try to do it yourself I'm
going to go over the answers in three
two one
so part a is our hypothalamus located
inside the brain part B just underneath
the hypothalamus is our pituitary gland
part C in the throat area is the thyroid
gland part deede kind of imagined just
above where your heart is located Part D
would be the thymus Part II there's two
of them one on top of the left kidney
one on top of the right kidney part er
the adrenal glands part F is located
right in between the two kidneys and
kind of behind the stomach although the
stomach is not in the picture and that's
the pancreas part G this diagram on the
right hand side shows a female's body
part G are the ovaries and part H on the
left hand side of the diagram that shows
the a male's body part H would be the
testes okay
so we've reached the end here if you're
in my biology class pause the video and
try to answer these questions on a
separate sheet of paper I'd be happy to
check them for accuracy before a class
or after class one day so go ahead and
pause the video and bring me some
answers and good luck